social distancing is more relaxed in
Sweden much of Europe has gone into
lockdown in the face of the
coronaviruses relentless spread but in
the spring sunshine stock homes cafes
have customers the schools are open and
the Prime Minister has urged people not
to panic I think that you know we Swedes
are we normally we are better at social
distancing in the first place so it does
it just feels that we are continuing
living the way it's about saving the
restaurants it's about saving the pubs
it's about saving people's work maybe we
have found a good balance but let's see
when it's over the elderly have been
told to avoid social contact crowds of
more than 50 banned but otherwise people
are largely free to go about their
normal lives this is how life might have
been in Britain too but then came that
computer simulation by Imperial College
London that showed that hospitals were
about to be overwhelmed a quarter of a
million people could die and a country
locked down but here in Sweden the
authorities just don't believe that
research the doctor in charge of the
strategy has been charting the upward
curve any deaths but he insists the
simulation was based on assumptions and
poor data I mean compared to us it's
hugely pessimistic I don't think any
curve in any country has gone that bad
as bad as the empirical shows this is
going to be and I don't think there is
no real connection being between having
a lot of rock towns closing Boris toes
in schools and sewing being safer some
scientists are horrified by the risk
they believe the authorities are taking
many lives could be lost I'm a scientist
I don't trust authorities I trust data
and I don't see transparency of data
that makes me calm to say that the
strategy chosen is the best way forward
but they might be right they might be
right and I will open a champagne a
bottle then because this is not about me
and who's right or wrong I think that we
should have an open discussion about the
scientific data the authorities are
building a field hospital
just in case so this is one of the wards
then that's correct this is one of
possible 60 wards in every ward which
will be 10 10 beds the first patients
are expected as soon as Monday you work
with medicine some frontier doctors
without borders did you ever imagine
you'd be building a hospital like this
in your home country never but I'm sure
nobody anticipated what we're seeing now
in all level sources I did sweden is
hoping to let the virus spread slowly
and aim britain once shared now the UK
is trying to completely shut it down
there's no way of knowing which strategy
will save more lives in the long run
Thomas More Sky News Stockholm